today we're going to be speaking with
Garrett brewhog who's a PhD candidate at
the University of Rochester working at
the laboratory of laser energetics the
largest university laser lab and one of
the only places in the world that can do
laser-driven Fusion experiments Garrett
really great having you on today I
appreciate it
yeah happy to come on David so I want to
talk about this recent breakthrough
that's made a lot of news in the field
of Fusion Energy before we even get to
that let's maybe develop an
understanding of what we mean when we
say Fusion Energy I think for a lot of
people it's it's sort of straightforward
to understand okay you can take
something like coal and you burn it and
then you can use that heat to do
different things I think many people can
understand that or you burn gasoline in
your car when we're talking about Fusion
Energy what exactly is it what are we
talking about what's the mechanism
yeah so Fusion is one of the two primary
forms of nuclear energy that we can uh
acquire right now what we do it all over
the world in fact what's keeping my
lights on right now is uh fission where
we split very heavy things like uranium
and utilize the heat to boil water turn
a turbine and make power to power our
homes Fusion is what powers the sun uh
it's also what powers our largest
thermonuclear weapons it's where we take
very small atoms like helium and force
them together that generates an enormous
amount of energy and we have never been
able to do a controlled sustained Fusion
chain reaction
on Earth without a thermonuclear weapon
until last week or two weeks ago so
Fusion is the coming together of atoms
in order to produce uh is it is it
accurate to say to produce heat
uh it produces several forms of energy
but everything will eventually just get
converted to heat to boil water or heat
up gases or something like that it's
it's kind of the the old adage that no
matter what Humanity does we eventually
boil water
okay so in other words fission is the
separation of atoms whereas Fusion is
the combination that's that's sort of
the fundamental difference we're talking
about
yes so the Breakthrough which you
alluded to at Lawrence Livermore
National Lab in California it's being
described as a huge advancement towards
nuclear fusion what what exactly is it
that happened
yeah so it is a really big scientific
achievement it's a huge advancement it's
been the the goal essentially ever since
we discovered Fusion to uh get a fusion
Chain Reaction uh in the laboratory so
Humanity has generated Fusion chain
reactions we did it first in the 1950s
with the ID Mike thermonuclear weapon
and now it's some of our scariest uh
weapons but that is not useful that is
just a capability we have we want Fusion
on a small scale controllable so that we
can make clean sources of power and that
has been very very challenging to do and
what Lawrence Livermore National Labs
did was they generated a self-sustained
fusion chain reaction in the lab no
nuclear bombs no gigantic destruction
everything was controlled and done and
is repeatable and that has never been
done before so it is it is a huge
advancement it's kind of like a Kitty
Hawk moment the airplane is finally
taken off what would it look like to use
this technology to generate the energy
that humans use for day-to-day lives
what what would do we know what a fusion
power plant would look like
yeah there's a lot of different designs
using lots of different Technologies
there's a there's a huge plethora of
ideas for how to use Fusion once you can
get ignition which is what Livermore did
um for for your average person it's
going to look just like a fission power
plant it'll be just a big chunk of
concrete that will make an enormous
amount of power for the amount of land
it takes up there will be no CO2 and you
might see some clouds coming out from
the cooling water and that would be
about it so with with our traditional is
is it fair to say that our traditional
nuclear power plants these are what we
would call fission nuclear power plants
attack here they split atoms and thus
they do fission at those plants one of
the concerns that exists is what do you
do with the spent Fuel and how long it
lasts Etc now I've said before I think
that those who are basing their opinion
on nuclear fission based on 40 year old
plants are probably not accurately
assessing them based on what modern
plants would look like but putting that
issue aside for a second you still have
this issue of the spent fuel in a fusion
plant
what are the source materials and what's
left over after the fact
so the source material is some special
forms of hydrogen but it's something
that's in the glass of water I'm
drinking from right now called deuterium
so that's heavy hydrogen it's very
common it's not a big deal it's used in
all sorts of applications primarily
nuclear but even in medical tracers and
we have effectively an infinite supply
of it
it would you know the sun will be long
burnt out before we ever burn through
the deuterium Supply uh the type of
fusion that Lawrence Livermore did which
is the quote-unquote easiest Fusion is
still very very hard it's called
deuterium tritium so the other input is
a special type of radioactive hydrogen
called tritium we have to breed that via
lithium so from the perspective of an
outside Observer ignoring all the
science the plant will eat deuterium
which we just get from water and a small
amount of lithium now we we get concerns
about lithium supplies because of
electric cars and things like that but
we're talking like a hundred kilos of
lithium a year for a power plant that
could power a major city it's not a it's
not a major concern it's just like with
fission where the total amount of
material going in and out is just
minuscule there is no direct nuclear
waste there's no spent fuel from Fusion
um it just makes helium but it also
makes an absurd number of neutrons which
is a type of radiation and it will make
the inside of the reactor radioactive
there's no way to get around radioactive
waste anytime we do any kind of nuclear
activities including medicine every
hospital generates a large flux of
radioactive waste but it's a benefit
it's cancer treatment and therapies and
all this good stuff
and we know how to handle the waste from
uh these sorts of systems Fusion would
not generate the very long-lived spent
fuel as you pointed out we can handle
the spent fuel from fission but ignoring
that Fusion won't generate it we're
talking things more like a hundred years
of radioactive Lifetime and there's
ideas for how to even shorten that
um so that that is one of the big
advantages that people point to with
Fusion what are the
um risks of this technology applied as a
power plant for example to power a city
as you mentioned what what can go wrong
and if something goes wrong what happens
um in some sort of kind of absurd worst
case scenario you could have radioactive
material released to the environment it
would be small it would be the impact
would be very low the general issues
would be things to people at the plant
very similar to what's happened with
fission failures you if you worked at
the plant you'd be worried you might
have to fight a fire or something like
that often Fusion is fusion power plants
are envisioned to use very interesting
weird coolant so you imagine like
flowing super hot liquid lithium I'm not
so afraid of the radiation I'm afraid of
flowing liquid lithium getting into the
air because that will make a very nasty
fire
um but these are all you know the fusion
is going to be regulated just like
fission it's going to be very very
tightly controlled and everyone takes
this job very seriously as to how it
would be put together I wouldn't I I
would be more than willing just like I'm
willing to live right now right next to
a fission plant I wouldn't have any
concern living next to a fusion plant
right now if my understanding is still
accurate it takes somewhere between six
and ten years to get a new nuclear
fission plant up and running
what is the timeline and maybe it's hard
to say because we don't yet exactly know
what these would look like but is there
a different timeline for Fusion Energy
plants
there is hope that it could be sped up
but I honestly think the sort of things
that would speed up a fusion plant
construction will speed up fission
construction as well a lot of the issues
that we see with fission come down to
just some of the dumbest stuff like
pouring concrete and laying steel uh
Fusion requires a lot more complex
equipment too so it's going to be many
iterations of learning how to build
these power plants before we ever get
good at it
um it's not something I would expect to
see even even if everything was ready to
go tomorrow I wouldn't expect to see
power plants just going up left and
right without massive honestly
government support you have to look at
how places like France did their large
fission build outs you just have to
throw tons of money and Personnel at it
when you
um look at something like or let me put
it a different way when you talk about
this being difficult Fusion being
difficult what does that really mean in
the sense that as an outsider in my mind
it seems to me that once you figure out
what you need in terms of equipment and
you do it you do it now you can
replicate it is is there some chance to
it where you can do the exact same thing
and it only works some of the time at
this point
so we are on
um we have just got an ignition
at Lawrence Livermore arguably we got it
last year but we don't need to quibble
about all of that what it is is we're
there now but we're only just barely
getting there
and if you've ever played around with
something like like doing a science
experiment
um where you're just figuring it out
there's often mistakes and issues and it
takes you just kind of have to do
something over and over and over again
to learn how to do it better but by
difficult what I'm actually getting at
with Fusion is that the conditions
needed to make a fusion reaction happen
are very very very hard to reach and the
equipment required is very expensive and
complicated when we're comparing to
other sources of power like let's just
take fission for an easy example you
take a rock that we dig out of the
ground turn it into a metal stick it
into water and the water gets hot for
Fusion we have to have some of the
largest lasers in the world
hitting little tiny targets or massive
incredible magnets that there's just
nothing to compare to now that's not to
say we can't get good at that I mean jet
engines used to be one of the most
complicated and incredible things on the
planet that only militaries could afford
and now all of us can ride on a jet
aircraft the aircraft themselves used to
be something that almost no one could
build
but it's we are at the like I said we're
kind of at the Kitty Hawk moment we just
got things to go we're not getting 747s
tomorrow
if we
zoom out a little bit
the feeling seems to be growing that in
even as little as 50 years we're going
to look at the status quo of cars
driving around burning gasoline pulling
oil out of the ground burning coal this
this is going to seem crazy for lack of
a better term right I mean it seems as
though what we are the the forms of
energy we're using now are going to seem
almost primitive compared to what is
apparently on the horizon is that the
right assessment
yeah I would say so I mean we already
have a lot of options that make uh
what's currently powering most of the
world look primitive right we can we can
already utilize things like uh nuclear
fission we have you know good
photovoltaics stuff like that the Sci-Fi
technologies here and it's only getting
better
when people say that fusion power
is the Holy Grail of clean energy
this is based on emissions specifically
or are there other aspects to this too
the claim the reasoning behind that and
I'm not all I'm not entirely sold on
that statement okay um I I think it's
I've heard it I've heard it plenty of
times I think it comes from a kind of
Science Fiction optimism around fusion
um and and a lack of understanding or
maybe not a lack but a nativity over
some of the other sources
Fusion is emissions free this the fuel
supply is effectively infinite like I
said it's it doesn't matter there's so
much it's it we don't even need to worry
about it
um
and those are the big benefits on top of
the lower radioactive uh waste inventory
but what I just described is basically
Advanced fission as well
and so I think that's kind of where that
it doesn't always click it's this idea
that if we got to Fusion then all our
problems are solved but that's not
really true one like I said it's going
to be hard to get these things out and
cheap and effective and reliable
but we have options now that can reach a
lot of those goals Fusion in my mind is
more of filling in this uh large
portfolio of various energy options each
of them have benefits uh and you know
drawbacks
and it's not just this science fiction
Utopia
last thing I want to ask you what's the
next step is it just to repeat this very
same thing that happened or or is there
some clear Advanced Next Step that we go
to
so the immediate next step is to repeat
and get more Fusion yield we think due
to how ignition works it's like striking
a match once you can get the match the
strike you can get more and more fire we
think we can get a lot more Fusion out
of the Livermore facility so they're
going to work on that as hard as
possible but there's already designs for
how to build the next laser facilities
uh to push this forward and there's
other Fusion Concepts that can that are
being worked on other reactors but
everyone can use the fact that we lit
the match to study how that matches lit
right and to to build these next step
machines I expect we'll see many
machines reaching ignition in the next
10 years and then we can really start to
evaluate what's the best way to move
forward for power
propulsion which is a whole other aspect
to it also yeah that that uh relates to
the idea of going to Mars and connects
with so many other things that are going
on fascinating stuff we've been speaking
with Garrett Brew Hogg who's a PhD
candidate at the University of Rochester
Garrett really appreciate your time
today thank you
yeah thank you so much